welcome to blueprint for efficiency my
name is michael puckett from the yale
clean energy finance forum and i'll be
your host for today's webinar
we're excited to present the first
webinar in a new series jointly hosted
by the clean energy finance forum and
the council for development finance
agencies the cdfa
this is the first initiative and what we
expect to be a long and fruitful
collaboration between these two
organizations
this webinar series will focus on
assessing creative revenue sources for
energy efficiency
and on advancing energy finance policy
in the united states
keep an eye out for invitations for the
next two webinars in this series which
are scheduled for april 7th and may
5th today's presentation is being
brought to you by the team at the yale
center for business and the environments
blueprint for efficiency
which is in its sixth year of providing
public webinars emphasizing the latest
trends and opportunities for energy
efficiency
each presentation is recorded and
available through the yale center for
business and the environment website
and the blueprint for efficiency itunes
u page
a link to download the slides from
today's presentation has also been
posted in the chat window
i'll hand it over shortly to jason
ridenburg director of research and
advisory services at the cdfa
who will provide a brief overview of the
work being done at the cdfa around
energy financing and the motivation for
today's for this webinar series
he'll also be introducing our presenters
today
doug lamb from mcguire woods
and colin rowan from the united
fund advisors
finally i would like to remind our
listeners that we welcome any questions
you might have
and we will direct them to our speakers
at the conclusion of the talk
you can type those questions directly
into the go to meeting chat window
with that i'd like to hand it over to
jason
great thank you for that introduction my
name is jason rudenberg with cdfa and we
also are very excited to be talking with
all of you today about energy finance
and some of the creative tools and in
some ways from the very traditional
tools that can be used to do financing
in this space
so after i speak doug land partner with
maguire woods will be speaking and then
calling with the principal with united
fund advisors will be talking and all
three of us today are going to be
talking about different facets of the
development finance toolbox and how that
can come to bear on energy financing
whether that's clean energy or energy
efficiency
so i wanted to start
off by kind of framing this conversation
to
by presenting a few of the entities and
some of the tools that can be used in
this space
you know in many ways the tools i'm
talking about are old hat if you're
familiar with infrastructure finance or
general economic development you might
know about many of these programs but at
cfa what we've found over the past
several years we've become increasingly
involved in the energy finance space
is that many people aren't aware of the
way that traditional financing tools can
be used for energy people tend to be
more focused on just the what we call
the energy branded programs that
explicitly say they're about energy
finance and so
one is to talk through the day some of
those entities that exist both inside
and outside of that energy context that
can be useful and then how their tools
can be useful as well
so where development finance programs
really all
come from are finance authorities these
are organizations that are located at
the state and local government
throughout the country that have the
ability to utilize economic development
finance tools
there are literally thousands and
actually tens of thousands of entities
in the united states that can issue
bonds and or operate other development
finance programs that we'll talk about
many of these entities are have so many
authorities that are given to them by
state and local
governments throughout the country that
they have all the same powers of the
green banks that you hear so much
discussion about in this space they can
do things like issue bonds they can
operate pace programs they can run a
special financing district they can do
loan programs all again those same
things that you hear talked about with
the green bank but they can do it from
your traditional economic development
finance entity
you might see them under the name of
this might be a special division of
development under a city government it
might be a port authority it might be a
state development agency
it might be something very targeting
sophisticated called a finance authority
or maybe even a really robust community
development financial institution can be
the entity in your area that has these
powers and oftentimes there's going to
be more than one available that can
operate these programs where you are
at the end of the day
this
these authorities operate something that
we call the development finance toolbox
and what we're talking about with
development finance toolbox
is a set of programs that can operate
across the development finance spectrum
so on that graph you see in front of you
right now
you've got a spectrum here from
government projects to establish
industry businesses to development
redevelopment projects small businesses
micro businesses and then entrepreneurs
these are projects and businesses that
have really very different types of
needs from each other and fittingly they
can't use the same type of program you
know bonds are most effective you see
there in bedrock tools bonds of the main
bedrock tool those are really effective
for government projects infrastructure
projects
airports
docks manufacturing established
industries again like manufacturers
development redevelopment projects doing
the infrastructure even the small light
infrastructure around a
mixed use district or multi-family
housing those types of projects are
really well suited for bonds because
they provide
large pieces of debt
and doug lam when he talks in a moment
is going to get much more into
that heavy debt piece from the bedrock
tools that i'm talking about here
targeted tools and tax and print
financing if you've heard of that in
special district financing really comes
from the planner targeted tools and
these are really effective for helping
establish industries for helping
development projects and redevelopment
projects they can be narrowed into a
specific business one specific building
or be district-wide and help provide a
very specific type of financing that can
help certain types of development
certain types of infrastructure and
other project costs including energy
the offset with with effectively
efficient use of public funds
investment tools can include equity and
can include tax credits as well as
venture or or other equity investments
and those are really flexible types of
projects that cover a wide range in some
cases you're starting to see them for
infrastructure you see lots of equity of
course with entrepreneurs and small
businesses but they can also come to
play for established industry and
development as well
so it's important that some place
in your community has some sort of
access to an investment tool whether
that's tax credit program
and colin rowan on the line is going to
talk about tax credits and other types
of equity tools a little bit later in
today's call
and the next capital lending tools are
also very effective these can really go
across the entire range as well
depending on the type of tool that
you're talking about but a lot of
lending programs are looking
specifically at small businesses micro
businesses entrepreneurs and they can
also be very powerful in the energy
space and then when cdfa is talking
about support tools as part of the
development finance toolbox
we're talking about federal programs
grants abatements and other programs
don't fit quite as nicely into the other
categories here but can really support
the financing of a project now one
finance authority does not need to have
access to all of these programs but it
is really important that within the
community there will be access to all of
these tools and if that can happen then
your community can support a wide range
of projects including energy projects no
matter what type of entities looking to
do them whether it's a major
infrastructure energy project or a major
you know infrastructure project that's
going to have an energy component to it
whether that's manufacturing looking to
improve efficiency or to do some sort of
combined heating power for example or
redevelopment project that's going to
have an efficiency component to it as
well
so
some of the specific finance authorities
that you can look to is great examples
that use those traditional finance tools
that i discussed in overview and then
put them towards an energy purpose are
listed here on this page ohio port
authorities are a really powerful
creation of state statute that allow a
local county to create a port authority
now the county doesn't need to have a
true port it doesn't need to have an
airport legal industry port
really the port authority can operate
like a development finance entity it can
issue bonds it can manage the tax
increment finance district it can run
loan programs they can run tax credits
and ohio has
five to six really strong port
authorities and several others that are
more one-directional and they do things
like run pace districts in ohio to lead
us toledo lucas county port authority in
particular runs a very robust pace
program it's been a doe better buildings
grantee
and because of that they're able to get
really involved in pretty sophisticated
ways in the energy space in the state
through what was otherwise the
traditional financing entity the
california state treasurer's office
is broken down into several different
branches but two of them the california
pollution finance control authority and
the california
you know i'm going to get all the words
wrong alternative energy and
transportation finance authority i
believe it's kaifa
they are able to do
very very robust programming they
between those entities they operate pace
they operate loan loss reserve funds
they operate a small loan loss reserve
pool loan program called a cap program
and they can really be a sophisticated
financing entity because of all those
powers that they have
new jersey economic development
authority the state's go to
finance and economic development agency
is now operating a special set of
cdbg funds community development block
grant funds from the u.s department of
housing urban development
and they were able to use those funds to
create their own version of a green bank
that's targeted doing energy efficiency
and other energy improvements for low to
moderate income areas
and as i mentioned community development
financial institutions or cdfis are
really
pretty typical
community development banks credit
unions but
several of them have been able to find
ways to get very involved in the energy
space particularly solar and energy loan
fund in florida and up in washington you
have craft three
so two tools i want to tease out in
particular because
doug and colin won't address them
directly necessarily in their talks our
tax districts and loan funds so first
talk about tax districts
there are a couple different kinds of
tax districts that are authorized in
various states each state has its own
authorizing legislation that affects
what type of districts are allowed and
what they can finance
but in general tax increment finance and
or special improvement districts are
allowed in almost every state in the
country
and what these programs do in different
ways is either capture property tax
value and use it to pay redevelopment
costs or add special taxes on top of an
area and use those fees to pay
redevelopment costs
and as a result of using these programs
there are a couple different ways this
relates to energy finance you know for
example we've seen special districts be
used to provide more efficient street
lights for corridors
some really interesting projects
happening up in michigan
using this type of authority and other
cities across the country are starting
to take note and see what they can do
you can put a district in place you can
use the financing costs to pay for led
lights or
as the district is put in
and redevelopment occurs you can replace
your existing street light
infrastructure with this more efficient
led based street lights
solar backup for intersections i know
because resiliency is starting to be
more of an issue for communities
throughout the country we've had talks
with a couple of different regional
planning commissions that are interested
in having more solar backups that during
some sort of power outage the community
doesn't have such a traffic issue and
people can still get safely for
intersections
also possibilities for creating solar
and combine heat and power using these
tools as well
loan funds of course very flexible tools
resolving loan funds involve having a
pool of capital that establishes the
loan fund in the initial place that loan
fund is then used to make loans and
principal and interest payments repay
the loan fund and so over the course of
time the program can completely recycle
and oftentimes even grow
over its life as more loans are made and
as they're paid back
similar to a loan program
same type of principle come into play to
create funding for a credit enhancement
model such as for a loan loss reserve or
it's called a collateral support program
or even a guarantee program
so regardless of the exact structure of
the loan fund you're talking about
some sort of program that provides
dedicated funding for businesses for
redevelopment and for energy costs
whether that's energy efficiency so
businesses can go in and become more
efficient or whether that's green
energies that businesses can help offset
the cost of
upgrading their energy source to solar
or wind or another technology these
programs can be very flexible
they can help
businesses access capital when their
banks may not be comfortable with the
transaction
but they can still be very safe overall
and they can help these projects move
forward so a handful of examples of
different
loan funding credit enhancement models
that exist and are targeted towards
energy
or small businesses and can be used for
energy our calcap the california
pollution control finance authority i
mentioned earlier operates this program
basically creates a pool loan loss
reserve fund that operates across many
small loans
works with bank community bank and
community development financial
institution partners throughout the
state to reach a large number of small
businesses
and the ohio port authorities which
again i mentioned earlier have a loan
loss reserve program that was actually
started with
qecb funds and is now able to provide a
backstop to
bonds and pace programs and other
programs they're going to finance energy
efficiency
improvements throughout the state and so
it's really creative model that's
getting a lot of leverage
and going to help
hopefully at least a large number of
projects go forward that program is just
getting off the ground here we're
excited to see what can happen with it
and some of you might be aware of the
wheel program that is hasn't put into
place in pennsylvania and it is
using
again a loan program to really help
residents get more efficiency get loans
that are low cost for efficiency it has
a great credit backstop model to it and
so it's able to make unsecured loans
that are secured at the fun level and
make very affordable financing going
forward for a lot of customers in an
important state
so
you know this is really just an overview
of a lot of different models that are
available i know in other talks
doug and colin in the future webcast
we're going to get into a lot more
details but i wanted to provide today
some of the breadth of what's possible
for energy financing through the
long-standing development finance models
that have been around happy to answer
any questions at the end and right now
i'm going to
turn things over to doug lamb with
maguire woods
thanks jason can you hear me
yes i can
oh great and um
i am loading up my screen right now uh
let's see here
and when it's uh i have
uh 10 20 right now so what do i have
till about 10 35 or so
that sounds great yeah
okay okay great and and um i think what
jason
covered was tremendously helpful in
terms of where i will be going
with my presentation my name is doug
lamb i am a partner with mcguire woods
in richmond virginia although not there
today but
and i work in the energy area and i've
worked on a variety of energy projects
what jason touched upon that is critical
when looking at putting together a
project or program trying to get
financing for any of these
types of uh projects that you know can
run the full gamut from
energy efficiency to traditional sort of
energy projects whether it's just
natural gas or some sort of electricity
production from traditional
sources or renewable energy production
one of the things uh to
look at closely is to start with the
locality
start in the state and then the federal
level because they're
as jason touched upon their program in
each state
that are different
and
and can be tremendously beneficial
uh
uh
to the ultimate project now also
you know one of those considerations
always to any of these projects is
what we see a lot on the finance side is
just
trying to
choose which one is the most efficient
vehicle and um and to keep it simple
oftentimes you'll see a lot of folks
want to
layer in a bunch of different subsidies
to
improve the rate of return on the
project and sometimes that works and
sometimes it doesn't it really depends
on all the project planning factors and
how long you have to pull the project
off but that's one of the things we
should touch on as we move through this
because
you know as uh
as as one starts to put a project
together and to evaluate what they're
gonna do they're really gonna
want to talk to the local economic
development
folks talk to their
professionals figure out what the time
horizon for a project is what the real
purpose of the project is
what they're trying to create ultimately
and how long they have to do it and and
and also figure out
uh who should own the project is it a
situation where it's a public private
sort of scenario where
uh you maybe you have private ownership
and a lot of public involvement and and
uh on the contractual side or is it a
pure public
uh situation with very minimal private
involvement except for maybe contractors
uh or wholly private and those sorts of
uh questions
will lead one down a variety of
different paths and and i think maybe
what colin can touch upon or will touch
upon which
is some of the other
uh vehicles out there that are
maybe potentially more on the
uh non-purely non-governmental ownership
side although i will touch on the the um
the bond mechanisms that are in place
for
uh
both governmental and non-governmental
ownership uh that you'll you'll
when you walk away from this you'll
realize that some of the agencies jason
mentioned some of the products i
mentioned and that colin mentioned they
all are usually interwoven together in
some of these larger more sophisticated
projects
and there are a variety of folks that uh
both local state national levels and
and the governmental non-governmental
side that are very
uh
uh attuned to how these things work and
and that's a critical piece of
moving forward
um you know one slide i put in here is
just to always
try to think about what the goals and
the interests are of the owners and the
investors you know to
really figure out
who wants what
i think
having those sort of discussions early
on is really important in terms of
achieving success
a lot of times these projects will
involve everybody
you know getting a little bit and not
one person getting everything and and um
if if that sort of viewpoint is taken
generally uh towards
getting these done it's usually a lot a
better situation for everyone some of
the
you know energy related
uh
if you will governmental uh programs
that are on the bond side
are either tax exempt where the interest
is
exempt to the income of the holder of
the
instrument or
the this sort of tax credit bonds that
have existed over a period of time i
have addressed really the clean
renewable energy bonds the qualified
energy conservation bots in the uh
qualified zone academy of bonds because
for
more or less the
school construction bonds all the
eligible for schools
uh and charter schools and
uh
have are largely um rolled off to and
i'm i'm really not seeing a lot of those
anymore but um
uh the
the
this chart this page five is really
intended to address kind of the
differences between them and really to
highlight some factors of
your in your planning stage who's going
to issue the obligation who's going to
own it
some of the approvals that are required
the type of subsidy that's delivered is
the subsidy
um
something that is meaningful to the
project is something worth the time
trying to get and uh you know is do you
have to issue the obligations uh before
construction can you issue them after
construction
all those are timing considerations that
one should take into account for any of
the types of programs and projects and
you know the the energy transactions on
the on the bond side go from the prepay
structure where you're issuing
an obligation to prepay for the power or
the gas that's delivered
to sort of output facility transactions
where
you are issuing from november for a a a
facility where the power is um
uh bought or you know bought and sold to
a to another entity
um
and then and then
the uh energy conservation bonds which
are very flexible in terms of
governmental or non-governmental
ownership
and the new credits which are
uh basically restricted to three
categories of ownership
co-ops um public power and governmental
entities
and i you know without straying from
energy efficiency too far
uh you will see a lot of these
instruments particularly qecbs
ads and tax exempt uh bonds or leases
used um
for energy efficiency transactions at
the on the governmental level it's very
common and most of the larger banks and
regional banks have those programs
these are some rules regarding output
facilities i'll
let you all read through that that'll be
these slides will be provided to you
later
and i've listed here kind of the in the
industry they're called private activity
bonds they're generally bonds that
uh where the ownership or use is uh held
in a non
predominantly in a non-governmental
entity find them a lot in utility so
you'll see a lot of landfill solid waste
sewage facility
but there's a whole category of these
all these that are listed here on this
slide a relate to
categories of bonds that might be might
be uh useful for an energy related
project there are lots of limitations on
these because they're obviously
providing a subsidy and the subsidy is
intended to be targeted so
anybody going into these needs to be
aware of those limitations and
that they will have to live with them
for a period of time while the bonds are
outstanding
but there is a wide range of
uh
instruments available worth
worth digging into and these and these
productivity bonds
can be used in concert with some of the
kind of for-profit tax credits as
opposed to the tax credit bonds i
mentioned
they removed some of the restrictions in
the recovery act a few years ago to
allow some double dipping there and uh
you'll find that that
could be a consideration when you're
putting a project together whether maybe
that can be taken advantage of
this slide really highlights that the
new krebs are renewable energy
producing
facilities
so wind
solar
biomass hydro things like that
and you know the qecb's are a much
broader range of projects everything
from uh that covers the new krebs
projects to energy efficiency to
research expenditures and various
programs and energy conservation and a
broad category called the green
community program which is i think folks
are getting more and more comfortable
with and how that works because it um
in part
they're wanting to get comfortable with
it because it does accept
uh the
it's exempt from the 30 allocation
requirement that uh no more than uh that
at least 70 percent of the allocation
for a qecb of the state be used for
governmental projects
um and so that's uh gaining a lot of
popularity i think we're seeing more of
those
uh just a couple quick
things on these tax credit bonds again
they they're they're we call them tax
credit bonds but they're actually
eligible for a direct pay subsidy um
if you're familiar with some of the
for-profit tax credit bonds where they
allow the grants to be paid in lieu of
the tax credit it's the same sort of
situation where the issuer of the bond
will receive
a direct pay subsidy based upon the
amount of interest paid
um and
when calculating the amount of interest
one needs to be aware that for these
qebs and credits it's 70 percent of the
of the tax credit rate uh and
that you use and then they're also
subject to sequestration still
so some important things in the planning
phase this slide really gets into
uh this is slide 10 and really gets into
the qualified conservation purposes for
qecbs again a wide-ranging uh group of
things you know candidly what we've seen
um most of the qe cbs used for are in
the first column on the left which are
reduction of energy consumption in
public on buildings
and
the green community programs i haven't
seen
one for a research
project and i guess the mass commuting
facilities i could see that being done
although i can
haven't i'm not aware personally of one
of those but there's some folks out
there that maintain a really good
database of
uh
where qe cbs have been used i think that
energy consortium
is one group that maintains a listing of
these and worth uh
uh
um
looking that up to get it they have a
good booklet of what's been used on the
qecp side
real quickly because this has been a
recent topic the new krebs
which
had allocations go out in guess 09 or
2010 i guess
subject to a three-year use requirement
those that were those allocations that
weren't used were just made available to
be reallocated
you can see this a big number about 1.4
billion
um
and they're different methodologies for
obtaining the allocation this notice
there are several cdfa has done several
presentations on this and there's some
materials they have available that go
into detail about the notice but the irs
notice itself is very detailed just
something to be aware of because that's
something that's going on right now
if you have a project that's a renewable
energy electricity producing facility
and um
and what we've done on these last couple
of slides
uh is um
trying to compare and contrast taxes
qsad's new creds and qecb's just some of
the elements of them and um i think it's
these are the types of things that if
you want to have a kind of desktop uh
tool that uh
you want to be able to look at real
quickly to make sure you're thinking
about them correctly that they're
available they're that's you that's what
this is for
um certainly
just like any of these presentations you
should always uh consult your
um
advisors about uh
about uh what some of this means because
it's really condensed for chart form
um and as i flip through it you can see
um
um what's in here now what i'm going to
close with are
some
some
and to hand off the column um or some of
these other incentives that are out
there and there are lots of them um
jason touched on
all the development programs at the
local and state levels
uh
and
and there are a variety of ways these
incentive packages could put together
from you know whether it's a tiff or
special assessment that you're seeing
pace develop now which is sort of a
special assessment tif type structure
you know just to for the sake of
illustration of these lots of uh payment
load tax arrangements at the state and
local level
um you know on the federal level you
have uh the production investment tax
credits now obviously some of these are
rolling off or subject to uh limitation
or you know haven't been renewed and
have very very specific requirements
um and and have uh limited you know very
specific limitations particularly when
involved in governmental programs so you
want to be real careful about mixing
these up but
new markets is an area where
you see a lot of
people uh try to
use those with other programs whether
their state local incentives or other
types of bond programs um
and then lastly of course for enter any
energy project
and you know whether it's broad category
the usda da and doe
department of energy have um
uh just uh
vast amounts of uh
resources and programs for a variety of
different you know whether it's biomass
biofuel whether it's
you know stuff that is not commercially
proven yet it's kind of a demonstration
project
and then recently the white house has
announced its world infrastructure
opportunity fund which is more of a in
the nature of a public-private
partnership so
you know with that i i'll be happy to
answer questions at the end and i thank
you for your time and attention i'd like
to hand it over to colin
great thanks
i'm going to just pull up my screen here
is that screen up and available for
everybody
yes colin looks good great thanks
well thanks everybody for participating
and
thanks to the yale clean energy finance
forum and cdfa for inviting me to speak
to you all today
i'm going to
try and keep this pretty brief and focus
in a little bit on um probably through
two main areas tax credit-based finance
and hand-in-hand with that project level
finance so a lot of the programs you've
already heard about um can be used to
finance various programs energy
efficiency programs research programs
the tools i'm going to talk about are
more project based
so supporting the construction of hard
assets
and typically larger scale projects
we've funded energy projects that are
non-utility scale um 5 million to 10
million dollars or larger
and then new markets which i'll get into
in some detail
typically used for projects seven or
eight million dollars or larger
so with that as a framework just real
quick
we're based in portland oregon united
fund advisors we're a financial services
company that provides tax credit finance
four projects we've got about two
billion dollars of assets under
management and uh portion of that is
energy projects um a lot of it is using
new market tax credit uh to support both
energy and non-energy projects
um clients include a whole list of folks
i won't bore you with but you can browse
through these slides if you want i'm
going to skip over services so we can
get to
the meat of things
so new market tax credit financing some
of you may be familiar with some of you
may not be it's a competitive program
run by the treasury department
and
the overriding goal is to stimulate
private investment in low-income
communities period
what that means is you can have a lot of
flexibility in the types of projects
that can be financed
what it also means though and this is
very important is that new market tax
credits
yields about 20 percent of the capital
stack that you're looking at for a
project so for say a 10 million dollar
wind project about 2 million dollars
will be net into the project as a source
of funds to support it low-cost flexible
capital
but there's
and it can be debt or equity
but there are you know particular
considerations you need to think about
when considering new market tax credit
financing for a project uh there's a
seven year credit or compliance period
and we'll we'll get into twin deals with
itcs which have a five-year compliance
period so there's a
two additional two year tail on new
markets where you're reporting from
compliance requirements to the treasury
department
you've got to have the other 80 of the
funding so you've got to be able to
demonstrate the the balance of the
funding needed to complete your project
is not just available theoretically but
committed
there can be challenges combining the
tax credit equity with traditional
commercial financing because of the
seven year compliance period and some
things that are asked of lenders that
they often don't like
and it's a highly competitive program
with a lumpy funding cycle so fun the
awards are typically given on an annual
basis uh we expect awards this year to
be announced sometime in the june time
frame and then it's sort of a feeding
frenzy as projects we're trying to lock
up um allocation from folks like
ourselves and others who often get
awards
to get closed sometimes within within
2015
and then it's up for reauthorization so
it's not permanent legislation so
there's uncertainty going forward
there's all sorts of projects you can
fund with new markets here just some
some high level examples
but it includes renewables
we've funded
biofuels and win projects with new
markets uh and solar projects have been
done um although the solar projects that
we financed were just itc only projects
investment tax credits which are
related to the
the development of solar projects
um
not to scare you but just again you can
refer to this and i'm happy to have my
information provided folks can follow up
with me but this is what a typical new
market tax credit structure looks like
and at the top of the structure you've
got your funding sources your lender and
your tax credit investor
all that capital is then aggregated into
an investment fund which goes down into
a community development entity or cde
such as the one that we run
which then makes the investment or loan
or loans into what's referred to as the
qualified that's the project that's the
borrower
so you the investment fund and the cde
are really passed through entities that
the new markets program
forces to be inserted into what would
otherwise be a typical funding structure
with debt and equity coming in
so issues with pairing and state htc itc
and mtc historic tax credits investment
tax credits new market tax credits it
would also apply for production tax
credits
there's technical issues but what i
think folks need to be really aware of
is that there's also
sort of subjective
considerations that you really need to
think about because new market tax
credits are competitive
groups like ourselves
need to underwrite to the community
impacts of the projects we're financing
so we want to see
really good quality jobs getting created
or maintained in the low-income
community
provision of goods or services which in
the case of energy projects could be
energy efficiency programs it could be
the production of renewable energy
which is either lowering ratepayers
cost of energy or maybe supporting a
municipality
or even a non-profit i'll get into a
case study that looks at that in a
moment
housing
other benefits for residents of a
low-income community and then
environmentally sustainable outcomes so
renewable production
can
kind of hit the right boxes
but at the end of the day folks that
have allocation really want to know how
are low-income people in their community
benefiting from the project that's going
to be supported with new markets
um case study i want to talk about real
quick just because it's it's kind of the
the prototypical new markets
itc or ptc project is up in
aberdeen washington it's the the west
coast of the olympic peninsula it's a
wind farm that was put in place by a
non-profit agency up there they got a
major grant from the state of washington
uh had some additional sources that came
in and then use both new markets and
investment tax credits to to get the
facility up and running
and they provide food bank services
health care services job training and
placement services housing services to
low
olympic peninsula so a really unique but
fantastic
um
else
there we go no that's not you yep okay
looks like we're clear i'm gonna keep
going here and try and wrap up in just a
few minutes so this structure is not
being presented to scare you away from
twin deals
it's really just to demonstrate that
there is a lot of complexity when you're
dealing with tax credit finance and when
you're combining two programs it can get
even more complex um in this case there
were two new markets allocatees and
therefore you see the two sort of
parallel columns in the middle with
investment fund one and two and sub cd
one and two
and then off on the side you've got a
master tenant structure and that's
typical for
investment tax credit production tax
credit um
deals where you're bringing in an
outside investor to buy the credits
but but this is is a very typical twin
structure it's not as complicated as it
looks five years ago i probably wouldn't
have said that but i think folks have
generally become pretty comfortable with
how these structures operate the
triangles are passed through entities
and so
again if you collapse this whole thing
down and get the pass-through entities
out you're really just looking at the
original funding sources and the
borrower which labeled the quality here
considerations for investment tax
credits
and this would really apply for
production tax credits as well
ongoing
extension of legislation similar to new
markets these energy tax credit programs
are not permanent and so
there's uncertainty as to the future
which means you've got a choppy tax
credit market
meaning investors sometimes aren't that
interested particularly in smaller deals
it's a one-year credit with a five-year
compliance period so the the good news
is you often see funding come in right
up front
but then you've got five years of
compliance where you've got to be able
to show that whatever your energy
producing facility is is going to remain
up and running by and large
for that five year period so the tax
credit investors are looking for strong
operators strong guarantors
on those projects
similar to new markets investment tax
credits production tax credits or gap
fillers you don't get the full capital
stack you're looking at 20 to
25 of the capital and you often need to
bridge finance um to that tax equity
because it probably won't come in on day
one
so that's a real high level overview i
want to leave time for some questions um
whether they're related to my
presentation or any of the others i
think what i would say though in summary
is that you know with
tax credit projects again you've got to
have reasonable scale on the project
you can theoretically have
public or private ownership
of the entity if it's public ownership
you're probably going to have to set up
some sort of a non-profit or some sort
of private entity to hold and operate
the assets um through some sort of
agreement with the public agency but you
can do it there are ways to
structure that we funded a wind project
in corpus christi that was
with the port of corpus christi but
they've struck an agreement with a
private developer to get this
demonstration win project up and running
within the port and so there's different
creative ways you can structure it and
partner up to get these things done with
tax credits particularly if you're on
the public side
if you're looking to twin new markets
you got to step back and ask the
question what are the community impacts
from this project
producing renewable energy is fantastic
and noble but that's that's typically
not enough to get new market tax credits
in you've got to have some interesting
public public-private connection some
connection to the low-income residents
of the community
the one other thing i would say is more
and more people are talking about eb5
financing
for largely real estate projects but i
think for for major infrastructure
projects as well
um and the couple things i would say
about eb5 we've got some experience with
it and have a regional center up and
running in new york newark and
philadelphia
with eb-5 capital it's foreign capital
coming in their their complex
structures
but if you have a credit
worthy sponsor behind the deal a public
agency
a major hospital
things of that nature infrastructure can
get done and it's something that you may
want to consider particularly if it's a
larger scale project
with that i'm going to wrap up and turn
it back to
the moderators to take any questions you
all might have thanks
thanks everyone so we have we have some
good questions already lined up that i
would uh remind everyone that if you
have any
uh anything that comes to mind or
anything you want answered please enter
it into the chat window and we'll
make sure to put it to the presenters
so the first question we have comes from
albury and it is directed for colin
and the question is around
how you see regulatory uncertainty
particularly around the ptc and the itc
affecting the market for renewable
energy financing and in particular what
you expect whether you have any inkling
as to what to expect
to the itc going forward
um yeah there's i think
two areas of regulatory uncertainty
one is sort of purely a tax code issue
some of you may be familiar with the
historic boardwalk ruling that was
passed down a couple years ago which
sent the historic tax credit market and
those who are active in that space
sideways for a couple of years
because the the nature of the structure
in a particular project in connecticut
um
not connected to yale was challenged um
by the irs
and and that caused um deal structures
and deal economics to really get altered
in the historic tax credit world
things are back on track deals are
getting done tax council is comfortable
with the structures that have been
arrived at
but with any tax credit program you've
got that regulatory risk that suddenly
the the service or treasury department
is going to come in and basically change
the rules change the structures
based on what they're seeing in the
marketplace so that's that's one level
of risk
and that can be dealt with and gets
dealt with as you're structuring your
deal the second risk is the risk that
was referred to in the question directly
which is the risk of program renewal
for these programs that aren't permanent
legislation they become political
footballs and i'm sure you all have
seen these things or heard of these
things coming
up for discussion as
tax policy is debated in washington
i don't have any insight sadly
as to what the future of itc and ptc
credits are that the one thing i will
say is they are in the grand scheme of
things relatively small programs
with a lot of strong advocacy behind
them
so
the little insight that i get is a
feeling that these programs will
continue
into the future indefinitely
likewise with new markets
but i say that with a huge asterisk next
to it because you just never know what's
going to drop off as uh congress is
chopping and cutting various programs so
not a very satisfying answer but that's
all i've got right now
okay thanks for that um the next
question comes from steve
um
and he wanted to know i guess touching
on what jason said in his introduction
uh what the role of green banks and
specifically uh strategies used by green
banks such as pace financing could play
both on the bond side and more generally
in terms of renewable energy financing
yeah um i'll start with that one at
least this is jason so i think that's a
good question
when you talk about the strategies that
green banks can play in the role that
they have in financing so you do see
entities that are
in some cases maybe officially a green
bank although i know that there are a
pretty small number that consider
themselves to be you know using
quotation marks or capital letters green
bank
but some of those entities do have bond
capabilities so of course the main green
bank that people point to is the one in
connecticut
and so the connecticut green bank does
have the ability to issue bonds and they
can do that to support pace they can
support a larger pace portfolio by
taking out kind of a big
chunk of funding to run that pace
program and then
you know bonds bonds have a role there
and setting up that capital
in
other cases an actual green bank or just
one of the development entities that i
talked about that wants to be involved
in energy projects and using bond
financing they can they've got a wide
variety of options so
i believe doug was talking about the
exam facilities bonds or taxes on
private activity bonds and those can be
used for things like airports
and
docks and mass transit facilities
multi-family housing manufacturers so
those are all
water facilities as well water treatment
those are all major
facilities that take a large amount of
capital to finance and to have
constructed and so to the extent that
those facilities are interested in doing
things like making efficiency upgrades
or
installing solar or combining power
biomass whatever it may be
bonds can be issued directly
to those facilities to help
provide lower financing costs on
installing those those clean energy
facilities onto those those locations
those are some good potential users i
know in toledo one of the wastewater
treatment plants up there has taken
advantage of
i believe they did the solar panel
installation
there are other places in the country
that have done it as well
also exempt facility bonds directly can
be used for biomass and for
i think it's
central heat and power combine heat
power as well they can be used directly
for those facilities doesn't matter what
type of other
building or
purpose that they're being put to you
can just issue a private activity bond
for biomass for example
so
i think that answers that basically
bonds can be integral to bonds they
should to a green bank they should be
one of the tools that they're using
because they can provide big chunks of
capital at one time and so you might
have additional thoughts as well of
course
now you know i the only thought i would
add to that jason is that uh
to your point about the breadth of the
bonds
there are a lot of projects that get
done as bond issues without a federal
subsidy involved in other words
they're done for
uh as a
they're done through their traditional
bonding mechanisms of the state without
a federal subsidy attached to it and
that's because there
might be
state and local benefits available
bestowed up by virtue of issuing that
bond and uh lots you know there's
structures
that will be put into place using that
in including sort of lease structures
and other structures that transfer
ownership into a governmental entity to
eliminate taxation
just
that would be the thing i would add on
to it
to what you said jason
yeah that's a great point i appreciate
that and particularly um for people who
probably haven't paid as much attention
as you have
and part of the reason for that you know
you mentioned you can
pair it with other state and local
benefits but then also in the interest
rate environment that we have right now
the benefit of that federal tax
exemption isn't as large as historically
and so i think in
again you can chime in if this is wrong
but i think
that's even more common that people are
doing bonds without that federal tax
exemption because the rates are so close
anyhow
yeah no i think that's generally right
great uh good answers there well um the
next question uh comes from john and
it's directed for doug
and the the question is could you talk
about some of the unique challenges that
exist for either energy efficiency or
renewable energy bonds as distinct from
other more traditional types of bonds
absolutely i think
one of the
one of the unique challenges of
energy efficiency projects
uh always has to do with the timing
of
um
in the matching of the
savings versus the debt service and the
type of facility it's going into
oftentimes you'll see
projects where um
you know the
the payout on the efficiency is shorter
than what they want to amortize the debt
so it can present some challenges there
and working with some of the
energy service companies out there that
are particularly adept at trying to
structure these projects so that they
generate savings that you know
essentially paid at that service and
also meet a variety of state rules or
requirements about how those savings
uh have to uh
be structured in order that a bond issue
can or
any sort of obligation could be issued
on a state or local level for that does
you know i would see the matching of
that uh savings and revenue
or debt service rather it's a critical
piece there on the energy efficiency
side
clearly as pace develops on energy you
know
across a variety of different platforms
whether it's renewable or energy
efficiency it'll be interesting to see
how that works on the commercial side as
well um
as it um
as local governmental entities set up
programs to allow for uh you know
assessments or what have you to be
uh pledged um
uh to
uh for commercial projects and and the
matching of those revenues and and
whether commercial entities will want to
have
as long as um amortization varies as
maybe a governmental entity whether
their budget concerns are different so i
could see those as being future
challenges there
on the renewable side i would
i would really point to the fact a
common column made about scalability
one of the one of the issues you see on
a lot of these projects is
the size of it and
the
funding the sources of funding for it
there's not a lot of familiarity in a
lot of places with
solar or wind at the governmental level
just in terms of
the finance side you know the engineers
may be very experienced with it
and so oftentimes the challenges are
just uh
those kind of two different mindsets
meeting and trying to get together on a
project i think in the last five to ten
years you've seen a monumental
evolution on
and
and
in terms of understanding how these
projects work and what they can do
um
you know one of the key areas we're
seeing a lot on the utility side is just
the kind of biogas
world so whether it's water wastewater
or even
kind of solid waste utilities trying to
figure out how to
generate a revenue stream
or
save uh
uh you know
lower their expense profile by capturing
um some of these uh resources and uh
reusing them
and you know i would say that you know
the big challenge there in a lot of
those is just the size of the project
and whether or not you can put something
together and have the time and attention
bringing the third party
professionals in i think that's a
real reason why when folks put these
projects together it's really important
to try to
bring in folks that have done them
before to try to address those issues
so it you know
those challenges can be overcome that's
particularly scalability but those would
be the two
great thanks for that uh so we are
running out of time but i think we have
time for two more questions um
first one comes from
stewart for colin um there was a mention
of a reasonable scale of projects
and stu was wondering what in terms of
dollar
values
is this reasonable scale when it comes
to tax credit and bond financing
i can speak on the tax credit side i
might defer to one of the other
panelists on the bond side for for new
markets
typically you're looking at seven
million dollars if total project costs
were larger
anything below that you really start to
dilute the benefit because of some of
the fixed costs that are incurred in
getting the deals closed the one caveat
i would throw in if you have a highly
impactful
project that's smaller than that less
than five is really tough but five to
seven million dollars where you can
really draw a bright line to the
benefits to a low-income person that
that can get done uh and i would say on
the energy side
it's it's probably similar um
larger than 10 is preferred um it's hard
to get the tax equity first deals that
are smaller than 10 million in total
project cost
it's possible if all the other pieces
are in place a big strong guarantee and
a good credit worthy developer
but those are the sort of general
parameters i would offer on the bond
side i don't know doug if you have
insight you can share yeah and
and that is um
goes to really the ownership question i
mean i've seen a lot of very small
purely governmental projects get done on
the bond side because it's easier to
potentially uh just to include them in
a variety of other mechanisms um it's
the scalability issue really becomes
when it's um there's some sort of public
private um that maybe there's private
ownership involved and it really has to
be a bigger project and i would
i don't know that um
i can speak
uh
to what this you know the specific
number would be
uh but
when it's a
corporate any or non-governmental entity
doing a bond for
a project you know i would say typically
they don't want to
really dip below seven and a half
million dollars unless there are other
things going on beside that bond that
allow it to
allow that the time and expense of
putting it together
to make sense
so you know i i hates draw
bright lines but i think anytime you're
looking below seven and a half million
you should start figuring out how you're
gonna pay for it and and uh
over a period of time and whether it
really makes sense from that uh from
that standpoint
and i you know largely would be
deferential to any sort of financial
advisor on that that's more of a
business sort of question than a legal
question
great thanks for that okay so we are out
of time so this will be the last
question um and it's posed by david uh
for jason i think
is there a good resource that describes
the different finance authorities
throughout the country
yeah that's i'm trying to think if
there's a good one
online certainly if you go to
our website cdfa.net we have an online
resource database that includes
resources on a wide variety of finance
tools
you'll be able to find information on
all the different agencies that i
mentioned and quite a few others on our
site
i think probably the best
resource i can think of that's going to
describe the different agencies and the
types of programs different agencies
offer is a book that we have called the
drone finance practitioners guide
but
i'm sure we have an online one if you
want to follow me with email i'm sure i
can send you something
the type of nc's i'm talking about state
level agencies and local level agencies
um
and so if you just kind of look around
in your community they tend not to be
too hard to find if if you start
googling but if you want to reach out to
me they can help you connect to some
good specific resources
great thanks for that um well that's all
the time we have for today uh i'd like
to thank jason doug and colin for
wonderful presentation i'd also like to
thank everyone for dialing in and
listening in and participating um
in what has been a really entertaining
and really enlightening discussion
uh i'd also like to remind everyone that
today's talk will be available online
through the yale center for business and
the environment website
uh please also keep an eye out for the
upcoming blueprint for efficiency
webinars
including our presentation next tuesday
which will actually touch on a lot of
similar uh topics the the theme is uh
the development of secondary markets for
energy efficiency loans and we'll
actually be covering a lot of these uh
bond issuances um
that
that doug uh mentioned
so uh this is michael from the yale
center for business and the environment
saying so long from new haven
connecticut